everything and um i'm the opposite like
we got a car recently and i would come
home and he would just like kept
like having those car videos playing
with like cars on different terrain
and stuff it was just so boring i
couldn't weep and he was always just
like what do you think of this you know
like i know
nothing he could bring home like a ford
dart and i'd be like oh
so i guess it comes from money you know
like i don't give a [ __ ]
i just was like how about the kind of
car where you can put your cell phone
and it just charges it you know like you
could just balance it there he's like i
can't
buy an suv based on whether it can
charge my cell phone in a certain way
and i was like that's all i cared about
but he over researches everything so he
dealt with his pandemic fear
by just watching a lot of like diaper
hacks
and like you know jackson's tummy time
tips like baby jackson's tummy time
that's what he did i would get into bed
and not me my fireman husband would lay
there in his uniform watching
like some like one of those you know
what i mean those youtube [ __ ] that are
like
so anyway with my first kid jackson we
were able to do sleep socks
and truman didn't take as well to it
runner was really amazing with sleep
sacks so every baby's different i'm like
please stop please talk
listen i i gotta defend him here's the
thing that people don't understand
so i'm watching a friend of mine go
through this right now he's having his
first kid
guys don't know anything about anything
like we
we all went uh somewhere for a weekend
and we were all staying in the kitchen
and i like you know i got real confident
and i was like
all right i'm gonna ask some questions
here like i'm gonna get a little bit of
education
and as soon as i start asking questions
like my wife is like staring across the
kitchen at me like ready to murder me
and i was just like so like uh you know
like that cord
uh what's up with the cord thing like
you know they like cut it
and she you know they're like looking
like what do you mean and by the way
the guy who's having the kid is getting
the education at the same time like he
doesn't know any of this
and so it's like i don't think people
understand
like you're going from zero to having to
be educated
it's not like it's not like oh i kind of
sort of know some of this stuff and like
now i just gotta learn the details
it's like i've never even heard of that
topic before now let me go
get educated and be ready for this human
to like be under my
control that is true and guys have no
idea they have some strange impulses he
was like can i put the baby in a swing
at the park i'm like no she's four
months old you can't just put her on a
swing she doesn't have
like were you just gonna do that were
you just gonna drop a four-month-old on
a swing and like see what happened
but all that being said i will say i am
kind of
like worthless too i didn't read any
books you know i just wanted to watch
uh serial killer documentaries when i
was pregnant so um we had a baby nurse
and she told me everything
you know i mean she just explained
everything and
and i was sitting on her bed at one
point after we had the baby and it was
like a perfectly made bed because she
just
does everything in that perfect little
baby nurse way like i'm like i'll never
be able to replicate this when this
woman is gone
and all of a sudden she looked at me and
she was like oh my god you're bleeding
and i was like i've gotten through covet
i've gone through everything
what the [ __ ] now and i looked down and
i realized that i had um smeared my
protein bar
all over the bed of this lovely woman
who's like helping me care for my
newborn baby
and there was just like fudge and like
cranberry from a protein bar and i was
like i am a pig
how can i keep a human alive
so that was kind of my experience i'm
not like a normal
mother you know and i can tell that but
if you start every sentence with as a
mother
as a mother yeah and then you just strip
protein bar all over the baby nurses
what's the craziest thing you've blamed
on being a mother
like what's the thing that you've like
just like ah no worries i'm a mother
i mean anything i'll have like a smear
of jaeger on my cheek and i'm like i'm
sorry mom
you know how like all those moms they
always have like they always have like
instagram headings like boxed wine is my
juice box or whatever you know so
i kind of try to get in on that like
i'll check my one with my whining or
whatever
um and so i usually try to do that but
with like
you know jager or harder flicker you
know
i'm like 10 shots of whiskey paulina's
been showing me these uh tick tocks
there's like a
like a mom tick tock uh thing and
uh they're all different moms all over
the country and they like basically
create content for each other
on tick tock where their kids are and
i'm sure the kids aren't excited that
their moms are on the same platform or
whatever
interesting but they're just like you
know when my when uh the baby goes to
bed and literally every video is the
same they're just
chugging liquor and i'm like okay
and so hearing you talk about jager i'm
like there is a reoccurring theme here
yeah but with them it's usually just
like a glass of rose or something
somehow it feels acceptable
um but my husband doesn't drink anymore
so i'm not as worthless as i used to he
quit drinking a couple years ago so now
it's more
it's more like just falling asleep
eating just doing a lot of feeding
in bed and passing out that's how i numb
myself
what's been the biggest surprise since
you had a kid
um honestly you know i thought i had a
lot of fear about it because i was like
what if i don't connect to her
especially because
i'm an over-sharer like i tell i'll tell
anybody anything
i have i hang out for like five minutes
and i'm just like so i still have some
anger at my dad but
i'm feeling better about it you know so
i was like what if i don't connect to
her because i'll tell people
i was like i'll be that woman at a
barbecue like is it weird that i don't
love her
like i'll have one corona and just start
telling people
and i'm like that'll be worse than not
loving her i won't be able to not tell
people and it won't be cool
so thank god i like i think i had so
much
anxiety about it and like fear and
focused on all the potential
catastrophic things happening on top of
what was happening
you know in the world that i didn't
consider
all the good and fun parts so it was
like pleasantly surprising
you know and i was like i loved her
right away which makes me a hero i think
right sorry my husband just walked in
and out of trouble
so obviously probably because he heard
you talking about the fact that
you were worried about not loving your
daughter
well i was like it is a thing you hear
about that women don't connect
that happens it doesn't mean they don't
eventually love in them
in beginning sometimes women have
postpartum or they have some
issue and they don't like bond is as
early a lot of women will say that they
don't bond right away or something and
then they slowly do usually i don't know
anybody that still doesn't love their
kids
but yeah the 15 year old that's the one
we just don't get we just don't really
hit it off
i mean sometimes there is a hole in the
team you know you'll see three kids and
you're like they
definitely love that one the most you
know not the other one
so but luckily we only have one kid and
uh yeah loved her right away i think
because i had so much
nerves about it that i was just so
pleasantly surprised and she's very cute
so i'm i'm pretty into it it's fun it's
like a movie like
it just she is entertains us she does
silly little things all the time
she's great yeah i i feel like uh you
guys seem to have like
done pretty well with this like
coronavirus
uh protest riots baby like
still alive you have a car
it charges your phone like there's
progress going on in your house
he's an amazing dad like does everything
everything does he have does he have the
uh front backpack
yes he has the carrier thing yeah he's
got all of that
and he's obsessed like jumps up every
time she cries when i was pregnant
he was like somewhat uh worthless like
we got on uh when i was in florida he
was with me
and then we went back to the airport
after we had to fly and it was like
you know may 15 whatever whenever uh the
golden state warriors guy
so and then he boarded the plane
without me i went to get a water i was
seven months [ __ ] pregnant
he boards the plane without me
environment maybe he thought you were on
the plane
no he thought i went to get a water and
i was taking too long and i got on the
plane i'm like what the [ __ ]
and he was like i just thought i'd like
get situated i'm like
there's nobody even on this plane there
was like a third of the people were even
on the plane
you thought you'd get yourself situated
i was like what the [ __ ] were you
thinking but he's
firemen because they're first responders
and maybe other first responders too
they're like
under reactors in those situations it's
like having an argument with like the
911 operator you know when you whenever
you hear
those tapes and you're like that poor
woman like won't she at least put some
warmth in her voice like
i know she can't say certain stuff but
just be like don't we'll be right there
they're always like all right ma'am okay
you know
that's what that's what it's like with
him i'm like where the [ __ ]
were you he's like yeah just thought he
gets situated i'm like do not understand
how insanely awful that is he's like
yeah i guess i just figured you'd be on
your way and i'm like
no so he was that he was that
he he may have just been checking the
plane for coping
making sure that he got it off before
you got there
i mean it was yeah it was astonishing
but then
i think you know what but the baby i
mean also
maybe it's something about a girl i
don't know i mean
he's he'll do everything for her yeah
yeah that's great